botaram é é de facto um privilégio estar
aqui convosco subiu falar de um tema tão
importante
mais do que dança do carna de dança e eu
é ao contrário não vou falar
necessariamente de mim olha que o sim ao
longo da vida para chegar onde cheguei
até porque não estou plenamente
convencido de ser um bom líder sós vezes
para inclusão no ar assim só jesus é
conhecido por todos os dias temos a
aprender a liderar e alterar melhor mas
vamos dar a minha visão de como é
conhecido o canal de dança começa por
partilhar convosco é que o que é nem
idéia do que é um líder o inter de forma
simples é alguém que tem uma visão com
sentido a oportunidade momento no espaço
que traça para quando chegar a alcançar
a ser visa um plano da ação mas que
acima de tudo entenda com especial
ficasse inteligência que para cumprir a
sua implantação depende não só de si um
substituto todos os que o rodeiam unida
é alguém preso durante confiante e
enérgico com superpoderes mas que
entende esta dimensão da multiplicidade
esta dimensão exponencial de todos os
que o banha cuidar e me dá força do
conjunto do super prover todos os juntos
a força ea múltipla que consegue e
portanto pra mim é um líder é que o que
eu pisar neste conceito do els
prudencial o eu multiplicador que vive
nesta dimensão uma dimensão que começa
por ser a dimensão da família
depois a dimensão dos vizinhos dos
amigos dos colegas de escola mas para a
dimensão dos colegas de trabalho
depois dos nossos parceiros dos nossos
clientes
depois dos fundos escolhem fuselagem e
eficaz conseguem um líder é um erro se
multiplica em todas estas dimensões como
é que se educa na liderança como é que
se cria um indivíduo com esta dimensão
multiplicadora
vou tentar simplificar em três grandes
princípios que são aquilo que o público
não sei se em níveis acima de tudo nos
meus sonhos meus filhos
são meu grande projeto de vida é acima
de qualquer projeto da fox
estes e os pequeninos na construção de
seus pequeninos são os que estão
ancorados essencialmente um amor
incondicional este é o primeiro
princípio é o amor incondicional que
queria ser autoconfiante com uma boa
autoestima a autoestima faz toda a
diferença e nós enquanto país desde os
pequeninos vemos não projetar neusa que
o que são as nossas ambições e horríveis
todos os dias sempre com um desafio em
casa começa a pensar qual o objeto final
que eu gostaria que ocorresse de nota
que eu gostaria que eles tivessem o qual
dá opção que eu gostaria que os que eu
gosto mas sem nunca voltar mas condição
eu escolher o caminho o objetivo final e
aquilo que se propõe em dia
completamente diferentes o objetivo de
cada um de nós deve ser aquilo que nós
escolhemos e por isso vamos lutar como
tinha sido completamente distinta
depois educar se estes líderes de ti eu
acho que um dia vão multiplicar passa
por ouvir conversar falaram dispus a
multiplicidade de culturas línguas de
comidas de experiências de música em si
não ouvir tudo desde a música quase
coloca o samba ao jazz e deixar de
escolher e deixar os sentires vai nesta
multiplicidade confortáveis de um dia
escolherem o seu caminho
mesmo caso de saques onda neste momento
em casa devemos não faz kizomba um pouco
difícil para mim mas eu estou feliz e
conhecem as músicas com mais nenhuma
este é o caminho do meu multiplicador e
ainda deixar de experimentar um tiro
veio do globo na manhã na massa do gol
embalou os presentes de natal mesmo fica
estranhíssimos usar o nosso computador
nem sempre correm cansarem os nossos
sapatos de experimentar
depois é preciso elogiar em campo dou
por mim a lei e mesmo quando as crianças
vencer livro de instruções
é um desafio que é difícil a gente faz
muita falta precisamos por nós na
internet à procura de soluções e lembro
das coisas mais extraordinárias
uma delas é sobre um viu-se é bom não é
bom do jear tanto pois ficam dependentes
do violão
viver saiu no risco não concordo com mãe
e como viver de algumas centenas pessoas
na função do desempenho hoje
estou plenamente convencido de que o gil
é um pilar fundamental da autoestima de
todos nós
primeiro um diu e reconhecer que estamos
atentos
aquilo que estão a fazer é identificar
nos valorizarmos o sucesso e urgiu
permitem-nos depois porque estão mais
robusto com um elogio para mim o futebol
estamos ser um novo objetivo e portanto
ao evocar um líder é preciso elogiar os
líderes
os líderes são aqueles que também serão
elogiado seus projetos varia entre a
frente com a mesma energia felicidade
com que os procurem atrás daquela missão
melhorar e tentar ficar oeste
agora já sei exatamente onde foi rasgado
gabriel ganhou design que tiverem de
sair agora e por vezes fugiu parece que
difícil a gente sair meu tá sempre uma
cópia podemos elogiar e fará toda a
diferença porque assim vamos criar eu os
grandes que são jovens adultos
confiantes produzir grandes capazes de
arriscar fixava e conseguem conduzir
esta multiplicidade dimensões por um vão
que chan atrás ciclo mesma energia com a
mesma confiança e com a mesma alegria em
segundo
é também importante pensarmos que a
extinção dos indivíduos é importante com
capacidade de conviver base com energia
podemos levar um de na nossa frente mas
vivemos em sociedade
e se bater regras de regras são coisas
boas
as regras são algo que nos ajuda
organizarmos regras existem em todo lado
as regras certamente existem aqui no
colégio militar vocês entendam isso
melhor que algumas crianças certamente
as regras existem em casa já que se está
a atravessar a rua
as regras existem para entrar e ser
inovador primeiro faz e depois entra
sempre para vencer lá dentro
as regras são algo que ajuda a sociedade
a organizar-se e um líder entende isto
entendo bem maior que uma regra promove
promovam vai maior coletivo não
necessariamente o seu individual é uma
história que todos estão muito engraçado
é que eu costumo contar também uma casa
que um empresa alguns na escandinávia
uma fábrica que tem parte desse momento
enorme cá fora e surge quando chegam ao
trabalho da manhã tipicamente para o car
não lugar mais próximo da porta mas no
lugar mais longe porque para permitir
que os que chegam atrasados pressione
mais perto e se possam ficar mais pressa
ao suposto trabalho
esta é uma regra simples que não vicia
necessariamente ruim do vivo mas promove
maior do coletivo
outro exemplo importante da minha vida
da minha vida atual e hoje em dia na
função que está em debate - com tempos
de pirataria conspiração conteúdos
consomem conteúdo pirateado das séries
penteados e há pouco tempo fiz um susto
no mercado e perguntar sua secretária
posso porque é mais fácil assim não pago
pra mim é melhor porque tem esse direito
e pronto
se todos katia santos certamente parece
que estamos a maximizar o nosso valor
individual mas quem é que depois iria
pagar a produção do ok 10 game of
thrones dos filmes da disney
no fim dos dinossauros que acaba de sair
no fim do dia
não estamos a contribuir prova maior de
campos por contribuir para um menor para
cada um de nós individualmente entregas
são coisas boas de um líder é que o que
entende o valor maior da regra e que
para a necessidade de alterar porque às
vezes é necessário fazer as regras
evoluir que a sociedade evolui as
dinâmicas evoluem
o werder entendo vai melhor que o colega
se propõe alcançar e altera não tenta
encontrar sua agenda pessoal
mas a agenda de todos da sua visão e dos
que seguem atrás dela
o líder ainda alguém que tenha uma visão
entende a arquitetura das regras e dos
passos que essas regras que confere mais
pois entende também que vivemos num
mundo de fluxos fluxo de pessoas
dinâmicas de energias de motivações que
vencer com vida
a visão traz um primeiro esboço do plano
depois vai adaptando a esse plano à
medida das oportunidades que surgem
sanar essas oportunidades e silas com
perseverança
sem desistir com força encarando em casa
derrota ganhando alento para uma nova
vitória e para continuar a seguir viagem
o líder é que eu que deve ser colhida e
só isso explica porque há pessoas
treinadas como john landis músico nós
conhecemos com sucesso na unidade na
balada
o jornal adianta que na verdade começou
por ser um consultor da bcg ótimo num
curso estados unidos e foi receber um
convite para lá com o bcg em bom rigor
poderia dizer com alguns nós atingiu sua
visão essa sua visão a sua missão eu
queria ser um consultor sucesso é ter um
emprego superman para ganhar uma fortuna
no entanto continua dançar com vida
continuando com a rudi que kanye west
finalmente ouviu as músicas que ele é
enviado para vários sítios reconheceu o
talento imenso e john legend de hoje
muito mais do que um consultor do da vcg
eu vi vera não o escritório mas no mundo
inteiro atrás da sua música porque
porque soube dançar com a vida tirar
partido dela e levar várias pessoas
atrás nessa sua essa sua dança will
multiplicador é portanto h em curado na
conjugação destes três princípios de
ordem como autoestima tremenda ancorava
um amor incondicional e que consegue com
isso ter confiança e alegria e levar
consigo todos nessa briga é alguém que
entende a arquitetura das regras o valor
coletivo e maior que essas regras tentam
alta
dançar e que respeitar hoje o mundo em
função sempre foi melhor do que o
latisse 300 consigo todas as pessoas
atrás nessa dimensão comercial e ainda
alguém que nunca deixa de dançar com a
vida que não deixe de ouvir o mundo de
beber do mundo viveu experiências
experimentar e traduzi las em novas
oportunidades
alguém que vê sempre o copo meio cheio e
no copo meio vazio alguém vê vantagens e
não as vantagens hpv desafio e não
problemas
este é o que eu chamo o euro comercial e
que ao longo da sua vida conduz uma
estrutura infinitamente potencial de
pessoas atrás se na mesma alegria na
mesma energia e na mesma posição que os
5 ver mágicos do que os falava entrar no
objetivo final
enfim a verdade é pra mim e isto é a
forma como eu tentar convencer conduzir
a minha vida mas acima de tudo pra forma
como eu encaro o meu desafio pessoal que
vai muito para além da fox e que o
desafio de criar não umas seis líderes
são os meus chutes e que ponha em
qualquer desafio profissional no ground
zero veiculava este é o desafio é criar
seis do líder deposto